encuentra el lugar ismo natural de tres
usando la calculadora redondea tu
respuesta hasta centésimos y bueno el
logaritmo natural de 3 no es ni más ni
menos que obtener el logaritmo en base
de 3 y es cercano a 2.71 algo algo algo
por lo tanto 3 está muy cercano a él
esto quiere decir que mi respuesta va a
ser cercano a 1 como 1 punto y algo
porque 2.71 elevado a 1 es 2.71 y
estamos muy cerca de eso así que
utilicemos la calculadora vamos a sacar
la calculadora y este es el botón del
hogar y natural ln es la previsión del
logaritmo natural así que lo que
queremos es el logaritmo natural de 3
vamos a ponerlo esto es igual a 1.0 9
861 etcétera pero nos pide que lo
aproximamos hasta centésimos y fíjate
que en el lugar decente si no tenemos un
9 y al lado un 8 entonces cuando
redondeamos el 9 se convierte en 10 es
decir que mi respuesta sería 1.10 ya
redondeado a centésimos así que déjenme
escribirlo aquí esto es cercano a 1.10
el logaritmo natural
cercano a 1.10 redondeado a centésimos